I'm not sure that there is a meaning I
really am at but if there is a meaning
it's going to be found in the service
you provided did you move the oxcart of
civilization along a couple feet or did
you just rest in the back or did you
just ride in the ox cart a lot of people
ride in the ox cart and they want to you
know they want to whip the people who
are trying to pull it and they want to
tell them all the things they're doing
wrong they want to tell them how much
better they could pull it if they were
doing it but they're riding in the ox
cart and you definitely want to be one
of the guys pulling it or at least
putting your shoulder to the wheel